[Music]
in vienna
the crackle of gunfire the signal that
multiple attackers had opened fire
in what is now europe's latest terror
attack
have been killed in the streets many
others are in hospital
some with life-threatening conditions
police have shot dead at least one
gunman others are thought to still be on
the loose
emergency services were called last
night to the city center
after reports of gunfire from six
different locations
many near the city's main synagogue
it's not yet clear if this was a
targeted attack on the jewish community
but it comes not long after two
faith-based attacks in france
including the beheading of a school
teacher who showed pupils caricatures of
the prophet muhammad
as well as the stabbing of churchgoers
in nice
austria's leader sebastian kurtz has
described the attacks as pre-planned
terrorism people are being told to stay
away from the city centre
with the country's borders being
tightened children
are being allowed to stay home from
school
i ask the population to stay at home or
if they are in a safe place
to stay there to follow the news whether
it is possible to take up
public life as normal tomorrow morning
that will very much depend on tonight
and whether it is possible to catch or
eliminate the suspects
and one thing must be clear and it will
be clear
and that is what the police stand for
whoever attacks one of us
is attacking all of us austria has also
today entered a new
partial coronavirus lockdown many had
gone to the city centre
for one last night out
[Music]
suddenly the shooting started first we
did not know what it was
but suddenly people who were sitting in
other guests gardens
started to run first we kept standing
there because we did not know what was
going on
then they were shooting again but closer
so we started to run away
because we did not know if we were
running in the right direction
we run into a hotel and hit them
while austria continues to deal with
covid this attack
a reminder of other brewing dangers
until now it has been france that's born
the anxious weight of this resurgence in
terrorism
but now those tentacles have spread
adam parsons sky news